india autorizó el uso de emergencia de
dos vacunas la de astrazéneca oxford y
una de la farmacéutica local barata
biotech el gobierno indicó que la medida
buscaba acelerar el proceso de
vacunación en una población que ronda
los 1.300 millones de habitantes en
medio de presiones por el aumento de
casos y el descubrimiento de la variante
de kobe 19 en su territorio la eficacia
de las vacunas queda como el gran
interrogante
astrazéneca indicó que la suya tendría
una de 70 42 por ciento de eficacia
mientras que de la india kóvacs singh no
se ha publicado ninguna cifra y se
encuentra en fase 3 de estudio desde
noviembre
luego de una examinación adecuada esta
reguladora ha decidido aceptar las
recomendaciones del comité experto y de
acuerdo a esto las vacunas de los
laboratorios serum y barac bayón text
son aprobadas para uso restrictivo en
situaciones de emergencia y usd en
amargas de segregan el instituto serum
la empresa de fabricación de vacunas más
grande del mundo fue contratada por
astrazéneca para hacer millones de dosis
el primer ministro- narendra modi indicó
que ambas vacunas
son hechas en suelo indio de
enorgullecer a cada indio saber que las
dos vacunas que fueron aprobadas para
uso de emergencia fueron hechas en india
el proceso de inmunización planea
vacunar a unos 300 millones de personas
a agosto de 2021 entre esos trabajadores
de la salud en primera línea la policía
y enfermos ambas vacunas tienen dos
dosis de cuatro semanas y deben ser
almacenadas a menos 2.8 grados celsius
países solicitó ser aprobada también en
la nación asiática y la aplicación se
encuentra en estudio india es el segundo
país más afectado con más casos en el
mundo reporta más de 10.3 millones de
contagios y unas 150.000 muertes por el
patógeno